yeah so explain who major taylor was so
yeah major
taylor was the uh first uh american-born
black champion in
any sport in 1889 in cycling
and uh he's so crazy yeah and just uh he
was
an amazing athlete um i mean just really
his story is
he was an amazing athlete at a time when
bicycling
was the greatest sport in the world um
and at a time when racism was was at its
worst it was just post jim crow
um and he and one of the elements of his
story that i
really think is is beneficial is that he
he um he partnered with a with a with a
man from indiana named birdie monger
bernie munger was an older white
big wheel racer who partnered with major
taylor
in indianapolis and ultimately moved to
worcester massachusetts to open a bike
business but i i think many people talk
about major taylor's challenges and
his triumphs and he was an amazing
athlete and there's lots there
i think the fact that they were able to
ally across
race in 1889 and he was he was he he did
his first race his first professional
race under 16.
wow his first rule was racist what were
they racing back then they so they were
racing road bikes and
and really when you you know the the the
real exciting part of what they did was
they were doing velodrome racing
so in madison square garden madison
square garden was
built the version in 1889
that was built was a velodrome get out
and they had
25 000 people watching bike races in
new york in the village room that is a
history i've never heard oh absolutely
it is unbelievable how big it was
um and the the the first his debut
like race when he became a sensation was
in new york at madison square garden
in 1887 and it was a velodrome it was a
six day so they talked about the six day
races
it was six days of non-stop racing
non-stop just going around six days nine
days you could stop
but the goal was to i mean this is
whoever got the most whoever simulated
miles
and more miles in six days
on a track on a track and he finished it
in madison
madison square garden he 20 finished at
2300 miles
i mean this wow it's just it's just it's
an
unbelievable accomplishment but you have
to remember
in the turn of the century the bicycle
was the pinnacle of technological
achievement like we don't really think
about that in a way
and what you said earlier about it being
a symbol of freedom it actually was a
symbol of
freedom for women for black people
for p it was you know it was it was
really the automobile was undependable
and horses were slow and
you know so the bicycle represents
represented something significantly
different
and major taylor and birdie monger
understood that like i
i really i believe that and i think um
that is why
he um for me really it was and i
discovered his book
accidentally in the basement of a bike
shop that i was working in
and and uh he was just a forgotten hero
he's completely forgotten
um i mean it's like a movie yeah and
it's and still we have not made a good
major tailor
yeah i mean i talked a little bit about
him with do you know who justin williams
is absolutely yeah so justin's been on
the show
and what he's doing in l.a with legion
is is like unbelievable right yeah
don't you think this is what you talked
about earlier in terms of the hip-hop
community oh yeah right he's right at
the cross-section of those
two worlds and he's able to bring that
sensibility
into that's right not just his racing
and being an elite
cyclist but into this idea of
of owning outdoor spaces that's right
and i i'm telling you
and i know justin actually i have a i
have a great picture of him with my son
and my son
ray spikes too and yeah and it was such
an amazing picture because he was
probably 13 and this was three years ago
here he was in town for a race
and i've talked with him a lot because i
also know rasam bihari really well
and just but but justin is what you were
describing he is that
young black american hip-hop generation
who said
i can really integrate myself without
you know he could be not about it and
and in that in that transgressive way of
not trying to assimilate he's like i'm
starting my own team i'm not going to
europe i'm not doing that's right
i like the fixie culture i think we can
do something here in the united states
and get people
excited about the kind of bike racing
that i excel at
that's the criteriums that's what i'm
saying that
he represents that sensibility and that
fearlessness and his understanding of
where the money flows right how i can do
it how do i feel the brand and the value
of it owning my own brand like that's
really powerful
and bringing that hip-hop sensibility
into the garments right like that's
writing a line that
is aspirational for a young kid who sees
that because that's right
it's freaking dope and you can't buy it
unless you're on the team so that's
right
he creates that like it's that supreme
model of like
you can't get it man you know there's
high demand and low supply
and i and that's what i mean i think
it's brilliant and i like i'm i'm
working really hard to try to get him to
come to minneapolis this summer so if
you're listening justin i'm going to
keep calling yeah
but but no but i really i really mean
that i think that is a
great example and i think even fixie
culture is another one of those weird
stories that you know that we don't
really realize that the
the idea of fixi culture actually also
has black roots
and it has black roots in the caribbean
community of new york
because when the caribbeans moved here
to new york the only bike they knew was
fixies
so fixty culture and europeans said
that's what's bike race
you know three spoke wheels on them
that's exactly making them all crazy
colors and all that kind of stuff and
that
drove all fixie culture in the united
states was really started by the
caribbeans in new york yeah
and yeah the the the true history versus
the
the sort of conventional narrative it's
it's fascinating another example of that
is um he's had selema masakela
on the show and he sent me his uh afro
surf book do you have this book
yep it's unbelievable and this complete
revisionist history of where surfing
comes from and how
in deeply embedded it is in you know
black cultures across the world
[Music]
you